gum breath let it fire back so today
we're gonna keep playing some doorways
remember it came out with chapter one
and two and it's the oculus so it should
be pretty fun
let's get into this [ __ ] alright this
game looks really good
I feel very tiny though I feel very very
tiny maybe it's just really big Hadar
alright I'll buy go in here then sure
nothing bad will happen at all this is
not weird this is a regular Tuesday for
me I don't know what your brother's
doing Tuesday but I just go into [ __ ]
weird creepy castles in the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere justice Yolo my wife
throw it you know I just want to say
what's up you never know what you can
meet around these alleys maybe you can
meet a dear friend shade sincerely doubt
but you know you never know like I said
I never know see I begged or whatever I
can barely see him Bank lights up my
fire where are we where are we going
here yes of course Bank yes of course
this is kind of [ __ ] creepy but
that's okay with me
Oh jump not baked banked banked are you
okay it's okay
alright let's go Yolo haha whoa whoa wow
that was a close one Bank wasn't it
don't kill me please don't fall down on
me thank you very much thank you
appreciate it
okay so far so good huh I don't trust
this Yolo alright so far so good you
double yo
I've got Debbie the trapping is in I
suspect they're not that friendly oh
[ __ ] what happened what happened did I
just get pierced holy [ __ ] I always
wanted a piercing uh what
Khanh supposed to jump over got it I'm a
pretty good jumper
they call me jumping doing back in high
school actually fat idiot loser that's
what they called me
oh hi how you guys do it it's good to
see it ah [ __ ] I thought I had some
friends god damn it
every time I think I have friends they
turn out to be dead what is this
wow that is close to my face the people
were tortured in this timeless place
what is this castle doing here Oh my bad
my bad not you banked can't really see
the text [ __ ]
I gotta let you bros pause if you want
to read it because I can't read it with
the oculus it's too blurry all that
thing don't know what it does probably
something really really bad but hey
that's is my opinion about things while
is in that cage was not Nicolas Cage
that son of a [ __ ] whoa what was that
why what's that don't spoke me Oh what
about here can I crawl underneath no we
can go here though but the question
remains is that some way we want to go
is that
hello
now what hell yeah with Dennett brows oh
my god
huh okay oh my god I'm like the totally
pissed person and whip our [ __ ] okay
we're fine so now we open the big bad
wolf the gate whatever I don't know
yep we're dead hell yeah high five I
don't know where you are
high five there you go all right open I
said open
what oh you open let me like pink
hey you go thanks you're welcome thank
it past our pleasure
why do you talk like that I can't
understand you
whoa this is a memory game Clark Clark
Clark what
like 4 o'clock 4 o'clock plus double
plus got it okay
fork clock uh uh uh plus double plus uh
fork clock uh uh uh uh uh uh
paddock egg ah ah ah
Yolo that's right big oh that's right
daddy's right high fiber us well what is
in here
hi guys what's up oh this makes it's
legit whoa we need to go there alright
let's open the gate to go there
that sounds good to me if you want Pete
I just want to watch Glee on
[ __ ] Tel Aviv sin oh yay oh [ __ ]
oh ha ha
okay what do we got fork clock uh bird
cage before what
Oh fork Plus+ breakage cool
okay fork claws clock fried cage fork +
o provide Kate Fork [ __ ] they are plus
watch oh [ __ ] I got a double bread cakes
and then fork [ __ ]
hell yeah half a bread half I it's like
I'm cuddling it ah oh hello girls how
you doing
god damn it every time I get girls they
turn out to be screaming [ __ ] god
damn it this is the worst day I have
ever had in my life I'm glad you're here
banked I'm glad they're pants good I'm
glad we're together we can party hard
well what is this house you should read
it okay well I'll do at that moment I
remember wondering is all of this just
my imagination perhaps now I should add
or is it a figment of the broken memory
of this maniac
man that guy's voice is sexy if I could
get pregnant then I think iam and I
would get in some sort of arrangement
I'm just saying I don't think that's gay
what is happening oh [ __ ] another one
there faster now fork fork clock plus
plus cage all shut Nicolas Cage okay
okay you can do is fork uh cork oh uh uh
uh uh uh
[ __ ] what fork fork pull o'clock fork
oh [ __ ] don't panic
clock don't panic don't panic
whatever you do don't panic plus we need
another plus I'm in fun
so close god dammit right fork come on
yay what you gonna do about it
see this place is awesome for ik [ __ ]
I remember for me brass pork God
okay I got it I got it no problem super
easy fork fork clock oh hi i+ birdcage
uh plus uh uh Clark Fork oh hell yeah
double high-five ah I don't feel like
that was much of a high-five [ __ ] at
the club way on the bitch's right it's
probably better be a good party that's
something I'm going through a lot of
[ __ ] effort often now that now let
thank you very much I hope nothing spook
is out there hello
none of those witches in the woods
please not a big fan of those oh [ __ ]
we're out of what Alice I really like
the level design it's it feels like a
dream kind of but still not a good one
not when I dreamt about Little Ponies
having felt great relief when I left
behind those sinister dungeons the other
dark halls and the whispers the presence
of those accusing tortured souls was
killing me at every step
how did we do this once in the clearing
the tranquility of having found an exit
was interrupted by the sudden notion of
my finding me once again in the dark
woods those haunting shadows were
starting to drive me insane
still something kept me moving forward I
knew I was closer than ever to the place
I needed to find I was determined to
discover the truth
whoever was responsible would pay for
the suffering he caused okay
totally miss everything about that but
that's okay Bengt come back to me thank
you thank where the [ __ ] are you hiding
committee a little [ __ ] I'm happy I was
taken aback well I don't give a [ __ ] we
have to go out [ __ ] at the club but
you had the club God I found all my
[ __ ] at the club
bang I gotta hand it to you you're
pretty [ __ ] bad like I can only let
him up for like two seconds before he
dies again alright there we go alright
why don't we go this is so spooky this
is so spooky I don't really know what
I'm going maybe here did I go back I
think I just went back how're you
supposed to know I [ __ ] I'm totally lost
oh oh oh I hate her so much I hate her
so much
good it's not fun with the oculus - why
why are you banked useless piece of eBay
crack Chinese quality that's what you
are where the hell am i right we're
going here yeah that was not correct uh
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
don't don't die on me don't die on me
yeah that's right you little [ __ ] what
you gonna do about good damn it Helen
well that should win [ __ ] well where
are we now there we go I'm gonna fall
for that [ __ ] again
you think it's light here but no it's
not
Yolo always works always right
whoa what that what what are you doing
here that doesn't have a mechanize henge
okay it's cool how do I go inside
probably not the front door there's got
to be like a latch or some [ __ ] like
that
hello anybody home I don't think so this
place looks this is like Bates Motel or
some [ __ ] like that
oh here we go hey or did it key for you
well I don't have one of those who
carries around kids these days I'm
cereal so is the music maybe we can find
no key somewhere oh maybe it's hidden ah
ah that's probably out here why of
course what's going on there you are now
GG hello Kay how are you friend don't
spook me
don't spook me I have superpowers and
they involve screaming like a little
[ __ ] that's my number one superpower
okay
it would appear that we are okay for now
we're now relics items I need mr. key
mr. Cate now bank that's right mr. hey
go hey you go don't really want to go
down there to be honest with you breasts
but as a wise man once said if you have
to pee just go to the toilet [ __ ] Oh God
this is spooky hello
anyone down here oh [ __ ] yeah I [ __ ] it
doesn't look good for us breasts not
good at all oh god okay I think we're
fine
I think we're totes mcgoats votes my
bros ah why do I go I'm sorry Bruce
I gotta end this first episode here but
I like it it's very interesting I hope
you enjoyed watching I'm looking forward
to play you some more of this let me
know if you want part watch oh that's
[ __ ] creepy man this game this game
gives me goosebumps anyway maybe like
maybe one part three it's a sky khon red
today I'll seen the next one before I
die
stop what what what what what what what
no no okay haha